trois trois personnes madame quel est le
problème trois personnes sont mortes
je les ai tué madame
madame quand j'avais une haine d'année
ma mère a assassiné trois personnes la
police est arrivée elle a commis ses
meurtres au cours d'un
exorcisme un exorcisme pratiqué sur elle
l'Église catholique a été impliquée et
on a transféré ma mère à l'hôpital
psyiatrique Cino à Rome alors me voilà
on en vient à se demander c'est dans mes
gênes je vais perdre la boule un jour
quelqu précaution si elle devient trop
agitée il y a un signal d'alarme au mur
Maria je suis ta
fille relie les
entailles relie les entailles relie les
entailles
maman
si vous voulez vraiment aider votre mère
vous devez mieux comprendre ce
qu'exorcisme vous suérez quoi il faut
que vous envoyez un vrai où Estelle on a
été obligé de l'installer en B au
sous c'est une combinaison de science et
de religion basé sur ma formation
médicale on
commence elle a dit mon nom
j'ai VO surist ça ve dire quoi diabol M
je vous
Prun forme de poss que j'ai déjà vu je
suis
désolé
r
[Musique]
les